I don't know I mean I do understand that
that people do get attached to this idea
that we have nine planets and that it
does seem a bit of a demotion
well the symbol for Pluto is just a peon
and I'll put together now Pluto was a
fairly recent discovery it was only
discovered in the 20th century and
although it has a name of a Roman god
just like most of the other planets with
their associated very ancient symbols
I've always assumed although I don't
know for sure that the symbol was just
made up because it's just a pnnl put
together which is both obviously the
first two letters of the name Pluto but
also interestingly are the initials of
Percival Lovell and he was an astronomer
and it was it was at the Lovell
Observatory that they actually
discovered the planet we have seen Pluto
we've got pictures of it from the Hubble
Space Telescope I mean you can see it
from the ground if you know where to
look
and obviously it was discovered with a
telescope from the ground but I believe
that there is a mission on its way
called new horizons which is a space
mission we have ignition and liftoff of
NASA's new Horizons spacecraft on a
decade long voyage to visit the planet
Pluto and then beyond which is actually
going to fly fly by Pluto and
investigate what it's made of and the
rest of this this newly discovered
system of bodies out there in the outer
reaches of the solar system called the
Kuiper belt so a couple of years ago at
the International Astronomy Union
meeting I had a big get-together of lots
of astronomers from around the world and
debated at length whether or not Pluto
should be called a planet or not now the
case against is that it's very very
unlike all the other planets it has a
different kind of orbit it sort of
sticks out of the plane where all the
other orbit planets orbit around it's a
lot smaller it's a lot further away and
in recent years we've discovered that
there are many many other bodies way out
there in the outer solar system the end
result after a vote was that Pluto is no
longer officially a planet our solar
system now has eight official planets
but the bottom line is it doesn't matter
it doesn't make a difference to Pluto
whether we call it a planet or not
nothing about Pluto's fundamental nature
changes it's just a label that we choose
to call it so
I think it's it's it's a bit of
silliness really to be debating this I
don't care it's still Pluto well it's
very very cold obviously because it's
very very very far away from the Sun and
we know that it's a rocky body and it's
also got a moon and this is a bit of a
strange thing because it's got a moon
that is a pretty large fraction of its
own mass and this moon is called Sharon
or Charon depending on how how you
pronounce and so the name of course
Pluto comes from the god of the
underworld the Greek god of the earth
the Roman god of the underworld and
Charon was the the ferryman that would
ferry the the Souls across the river
Styx into the underworld
so the name Pluto was actually suggested
not by professional astronomer but by an
11-year old girl and this girl who
became and lived into a ripe old age
unfortunately just passed away last week
I think as we're filming this work a
couple of weeks ago her name was
Venetia I'm not sure what her last name
was but when Pluto was discovered it was
the end of quite a long long search for
this mythical or hypothesized extra
planet and it made headlines around the
world and that was the the prerogative
of the astronomers at the Lowell
Observatory to actually choose the name
but they weren't coming up with with
very many acceptable ideas what were
they coming up with um I think one of
the names was after the wife of the
director or something like that you know
nothing particularly catchy and this
little girl living in England at the
time read about this in the newspaper
and suggested to her grandfather that
Pluto would be a good name and her
grandfather worked at Oxford University
in the library he made the suggestion to
the professor of astronomer astronomy
there and this suggestion made it back
across to to the Lowell Observatory and
in the end they voted on three different
names I'm not sure what the other two
were but Pluto got all of the votes not
competition now of course a lot of
people know the name Pluto as being the
name of Disney character and many people
think that the planet was actually named
after the Disney character but in fact
it's the other way around the planet
came first and Pluto the dog came later
back when Pluto was considered a planet
it was at sometimes closer to the Sun
than Neptune was so it wasn't the
furthest planet and the reason for this
is another thing that makes Pluto quite
odd relative to the other planets is
that most of the planets orbit the Sun
in the plane of the ecliptic so if you
look down on the solar system they all
kind of happily live in this nice
disk around the Sun but Pluto doesn't
pluto is oriented like this it's got
this big elliptical orbit that sort of
plunges through the plane of the
ecliptic so in certain configurations
you can imagine that during the relative
orbits of Pluto and Neptune sometimes
Pluto could be a little bit closer to
the Sun than Neptune could be so the
Kuiper belt objects are just this
collection of objects in the very outer
reaches of the solar system and you can
think of them as just the remnants of
what's left over after planet formation
so just a lot of junk out there a lot of
rock a lot of icy bodies and we just
haven't found them until recently
because obviously they're very very far
away and they're very dim and they're
very hard to find so you're sorry Pluto
is just a big piece of junk oh and they
don't put words in my mouth I'll go as
far as to say that no it probably isn't
isn't it planet but I'm not going to
slander it by calling it a piece of junk
it's an interesting part of our solar
system